ihr habt euch für einen plan entschieden
und leer wird auch durchgezogen um
appartement die von markus jetzt aber
wirklichkeit werden zu lassen muss
natürlich erst mal alles raus was sich
gerade noch in der wohnung befindet also
herzlich willkommen zum abriss der
wohnung um damit bruchbude zutrauen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und damit herzlich willkommen zum ersten
echten wahrhaftigen umbau video wir
werden in diesem video die komplette
wohnung rausreißen über das fahrt zum
bodensee küche zur heizung einfach alles
wir entkernen die komplette wohnung
natürlich habe ich das nicht alleine ich
bin aber heute alleine und probiere
einfach irgendwo einen anfang zu finden
ohne den eigentlichen plan zu haben was
ich eigentlich mache und wie das
funktioniert wir schauen uns erst mal an
wo wir haben
wir startet im bad das ist das erste was
ich dann auch wieder aufbauen will wenn
es denn mal ausgerissen ist das muss
raus dass man es los das muss läuft die
heizung muss raus das ding ist hier hat
alles irgendwie was mit wasser zu tun
und das ist genauso die elektrik
eigentlich was wo ich mich nicht dran
wagen sollte ohne ahnung zu haben die
schau jetzt einfach parallel ein paar
videos und probiere erstmal hier alles
abzustoßen damit wir dann mit einem
stemmeisen oder zumindest von trifft
ding hier die ganzen fliesen abbekommen
und wie irgendwie an die basis dieser
runden kommen um wieder sachen rein zu
tun vielleicht starte ich auch als erste
mit den sachen wo ich nichts falsch
machen kann die spiegel und so und
ansonsten muss ich mir das irgendwie
zusammen reimen oder bei youtube finden
aber genau dafür war ich ja dieses
projekt um sachen zu lernen die ich bis
dato noch nicht weiß in den nächsten
tagen werden hoffentlich dann leute dazu
kommen die mehr ahnung haben gerade wenn
es mehrere richtung electric geht aber
irgendwie muss das jetzt hier alles raus
könnte jetzt schlau sein und den
handtuchhalter probieren vernünftig
abzumachen auf der anderen seite wird
das alles neu gemacht deswegen kann ich
auch einfach mit gewalt
[Musik]
damit ist auch die erste fliese ab kein
problem
ihr fragt euch aber vermutlich mit recht
wie wir diese coolen podium 360 grad
aufnahmen haben die antwort ist ganz
einfach 36 der partner des heutigen die
aufnahmen sind genau wie die handhabung
so einfach wie genial starten wir mit
der in sexy co2 die ungefähr so klein
ist wie ein daumen und dadurch völlig
neue befestigungsmöglichkeiten bietet
beispielsweise aber kappe mit dem easy
jet super unauffällig auf hochtouren mit
dem magnet anhänger oder so ziemlich
überall mit der dreh halterung an jeder
wand einer scheibe oder wo auch immer
ihr wollt dazu unheimlich gute
bildstabilisierung tolle farben und
natürlich beste aufnahmequalität das
ganze wird nur noch durch das case
getoppt indem man die kamera verstauen
kann indem sie gleichzeitig lädt und
über das man sie steuern kann egal wo
sie gerade montiert ist ohne sie
abnehmen allerdings ähnlich einfach und
genial ist ins natürlich 64 x2 welche
für alle 360 grad aufnahmen
verantwortlich ist die in diesem video
gesehen habt und noch sehen werde
unheimlich kompaktes design und einfache
handhabung ergeben in kombination mit
der installateur sechs die app aufnahmen
echt fast surreal aussehen und als von
super besonders sind angefangen beim
raps ist bei denen mir garantiert nicht
mehr verpasst weil die kamera in alle
richtungen hinüber zu drohen ähnliche
aufnahmen die er mit dieser kamera
imitieren können ist so ziemlich alles
möglich der kreativität sind keine
grenzen gesetzt und auch hier übernimmt
die app dank cleverer kathi funktionen
eine menge arbeit zu euch um eure
aufnahmen direkt übers handy zu fertigen
videoclips zu vermeiden jak die kameras
über den ersten link in der video
beschreibung ab wenn sie ihr interesse
wecken konnten ich bedanke mich vielmals
bei ins taxi für die unterstützung
dieses projektes und wünsche euch
vertrieb was weiter mit dem gebiet
umfasst ist das ja ich glaube dass die
lüftung geisteskrank gut funktioniert
ist wirklich wenig an aber wie soll in
diesem ding die abluft aus dem fahrrad
in irgendeiner weise funktionieren kann
mir das jemand erklären ich denke nicht
dass smart mozart
es gibt nur ein problem das war so
ziemlich alles was ich in diesem bad
ablösen kann ohne dass irgendwas mit
wasser zu tun haben möglicherweise werde
ich jetzt wirklich youtube videos
schauen müssen um beim rest
weiterzumachen
[Musik]
ich habe kein eck ventil
aber carlo
grundsätzliche frage wird gern den
heizkörper montieren der spricht da von
amec ventil ich habe aber kein eck
ventil wo ich was zu drehen kann
nicht
sein weil ich dachte ich könnte hier
weitermachen [ __ ] ich kann die heizung
nicht alleine ab machen na gut dann
erstmal waschbecken und toilette
[Musik]
weiß wie lange das war schon drin ist
farbiger
kein problem
[Musik]
eines
heiliger das ist perfekt und jetzt mache
ich genau das gleiche nur in groß und
deutlich ekelhafter mit der toilette
ich mach das einfach alles ein bisschen
[Musik]
mein lieber geht es dir an den kragen
ich schwimme im scheiße wieder komplett
klar
ich hole meine handschuhe das mache ich
ja ich sie ganz ohne handschuhe
geil würde fast sagen level 1 vernünftig
gemeistert es geht es ans level 2 den
spaßigen part darauf habe ich schon die
ganze zeit gefragt mit dem stellenweise
oder so jede fliese hier von der wand
und schnelle vogelfreund was für die
ohren
[Musik]
liga ich dachte wirklich mein held er
einmal drauf und die fliesen kommen in
einem teil ab wie dumm ist wahr
[Musik]
es muss irgendein trick geben fliesen
abgeschlagen
[Musik]
ich brauche eine pause scheinbar gibt es
keinen trick das ist einfach nur
anstrengend aber es gehört dazu und
tatsächlich macht auch das box fast so
ein bisschen meditativer arbeit
zumindest denke ich wenn man das einmal
macht aber daran also leute die das
jeden tag machen ist auf jeden fall
nicht mehr ins fitnessstudio gehen aber
es macht richtig so tag nummer eins ist
geschafft ich würde sehr gerne weiter
machen aber ich komme der abendruhe
beteiligten aber nicht mehr mit den
nachbarn natürlich nicht verscherzen
dafür jetzt morgen direkt weiter wohl
nicht mehr dass auch unterstützung das
ist der aktuelle stand das ist auch der
aktuelle stand und ich bin super happy
wir sehen uns morgen wieder
tag nummer zwei auf baustelle casa
henrichs kann man so baustelle doch kann
sich wirklich sehen lassen wir müssen
entscheiden was soll ich euch erzählen
das muss weiter geballert werden die
fliesen müssen von der wand und genau
das mache ich jetzt
[Musik]
ich würde sagen ungefähr halbzeit im bad
zumindest was raus riss angeht ganz
krise geht gleich garantiert noch die
badewanne und natürlich die heizung
sanitär atze hat leider gestern
getrunken verspätet sich deswegen etwas
[Musik]
parisi alter
klein hier steht so wenig scheiß in der
wohnung um tatkräftige unterstützung die
erste professionelle person hier wohne
carlo hobby von mir sanitär hatte ich
schon angekündigt sag ich mal den
aktuellen stand bestatten im bad nach
wie vor problematisch mit der heizung
wir uns später darum aber heizkörper
aber es sieht ansonsten wunderbar aus
die badewanne muss noch raus dass ihr
muss dann natürlich noch los und der
heizkörper hier aber die küche stand
sieht es auch schon deutlich besser aus
und diese wand hier soll ja komplett
eingerissen werden und im großen raum
sehen wir hier den einbauschrank den wir
uns jetzt als nächstes vor knüpfen aber
es geht richtig gut voran und ich habe
das gefühl dass wir mit sicherheit heute
wenn alles mit den heizkörpern klappt
alles raus bekommen außer vielleicht dem
boden also die wand noch den schrank
irgendwie so jetzt probieren wir uns
erst mal am schrank
[Musik]
tomtom skatepark direkt auf die
baustelle
[Musik]
so stabil
wir sind komplett fertig mit dem schrank
das hier war er mal das ist carlo
hier ist jetzt endlich platzt und man
hat wirklich schon das gefühl obwohl es
hier immer noch voll steht dass der raum
deutlich größer geworden ist einfach
weil der schrank weg ist die wand hinter
mir schaffen wir wahrscheinlich heute
nicht mehr unter dem boden hat sich
gezeigt liegt teppichboden haben wir
zumindest einen punkt wo wir anfangen
können den boden rauszureißen aber
natürlich dann noch mal extra arbeit
weil wir den teppich raus müssen glaube
ich auch nicht so besonders geile arbeit
aber was soll's nächstes problem also
erstmal müssen wir hier natürlich auch
alles weg machen und das hier ist alles
gemauert das war mir nicht bewusst mit
diesem kleinen winzling kommen wir damit
nicht vernünftig dadurch
[Musik]
die wanderung muss geflext werden damit
sie durch diese kleine türchen durch
passt und das probiere ich alles morgen
zu machen also morgen wanderer aus
diesen scheiß raus war aus und boden
raus das wäre der traum ob das klappt
keine ahnung jetzt erstmal die ganzen
müll beseitigen dann sehen wir weiter
[Musik]
probleme sind nur dornige chancen gerade
im bezug auf die gestrigen informationen
zu christian lindner ist dieser satz
absolut angebracht wir haben eine lösung
für die stämme thematik wir haben ein
größeres stemmeisen organisiert und
werden uns jetzt vorerst um das bad
kümmern das problem ist wir haben die
wanderer unten auf gemacht und es riecht
wirklich modick es riecht wirklich nass
aber es ist kein problem wir müssen
jetzt gleich mal nach wien us dass da
unten wirklich ist und haben dann auch
absolute klarheit fangen jetzt aber an
mit dem stemmen boden ist heute dran
band ist dran und das bad wir starten
oder mama
[Musik]
und da sag ich mal so etwas lieber nach
hätte man darauf kommen ziemlich
schlecht von
den forscher kammer sie habe nun
ein denkmal gebaut ein tribut an
zingster 2000 irgendwas auf der
playstation 2 wir werden jetzt schauen
wie sich die band verhält wenn ich dabei
in bar
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit unterstützung von meinem hobby
finden haben wir auch ziemlich schnell
die eingemauerte unheimlich schwere guss
badewanne freischwimmen können und sie
dann aus dem bett heraus katapultiert
paroubek katapultiert ich sagen verpacke
ich so bei diesem preis oper aufnahmen
also problematisch die badewanne kämpft
mit irgendwann lässt sich nicht aus dem
badezimmer befreien das ist der absolute
horror hier zeigte einmal den boden ja
wunderbar kriegen wir heute alles nicht
mehr weg die kölner abraum leute wollen
samstag scheinbar nicht arbeiten was ich
verstehen kann aber die türzarge die wir
aus machen müssen damit die wanne
rausgeht gestaltet sich auch wieder
schwieriger als gedacht werden muss
auch dass wieder zerstören
wie sieht es hinter mir wir haben so
ziemlich alles geschafft was wir uns
vorgenommen haben wand ist raus bad ist
raus boden ist raus und hat dabei ein
teppich erwartet dem wir nicht
vorhersehen konnten im nächsten video
nächsten sonntag seht ihr hoffentlich
wie das bad zusammenkommt wir haben hier
die letzten drei tage richtig
durchgekocht es macht eine menge bock
wir müssen aber jetzt hier zu ende
machen weil wir wieder an der abend uhr
angekommen sind und ich die mieter nicht
weiter belästigen will vergesst nicht
den kanal zu abonnieren wenn es euch
gefallen hat vielen dank an ins taxi für
die unterstützung lässt dem video ein
leichter und wir sehen uns nächste woche
sonntag wieder couscous macht's gut